bien sûr non mais je te jure elle m'a
saoulé là mais crie jamais là appelle
papa c'est mieux
euh il va te défoncer en plus je rigole
vén contre en plus appelle c'est appelle
appelle papa c'est mieux par qu'il va te
défoncer
au comme ça ta s t'inquiète merci en
tout cas d'être là euh on va revenir sur
la cérémonie Miss France il arrivé une
petite galère juste avant son discours à
Miss Pays de la Loire ça concerne sa
robe un peu trop péchancré et forcément
sur X ils onont capté direct regardez il
s'agit de
attention Miss Pays de la
[Applaudissements]
Loire ça va ça va en fait c'est alors
cette année pendant les discours les
discours c'est dur et franchement et les
questions qui vous pose frère c'est le
bacfilo c'est quoi cette question là
quand tu es plus que 5 là c'est quoi ça
tuas eu quoi comme question toi déjà
alors moi j'ai la question question sur
les qualités qu'une Miss pour avoir et
qui démarquer des autres ouais mais
c'est encore toi tu t'en es bien sorti
avec la question parce que les autres
elles ont eu des questions maman
W moi je dis j'enlève les chares
laissez-moi tranquille laissez-moi
tranquille je veux pas je veux pas
enlever les talons enlever tout
laissez-moi tranquille alors cette année
on a eu le droit à quelques moments de
chaîne entre celle il y en a qui
oublient leurs discours celle qui
chantent et puis il y a eu des
répétitions on vous a sélectionner les
meilleurs mais faut le dire c'est en
direct c'est pas évident et c'est
souvent là que ça joue toi tu as été
très bonne sur le discours merci et
aussi après elle avait un petit problème
elle elle mettait pas bien son micro
ouais tu vois mais sinon sinon elle
était naturelle et toi aussi ça ça a
coulé tuavais bien préparé alors oui ben
après moi je me suis amusée hein moi moi
c'était de m'amuser cétait le mot
principal en fait j'étais à l'aise et
puis j'avais juste envie de profiter de
ce moment parce que c'est on vit que ça
qu'une seule fois dans notre vie donc
faut profiter pour pas avoir de regret
hein et pour rectifier en fait on avait
un body avec le body de l'ouverture en
fait on mettait juste une petite jupe
pour pouvoir donner cet effet on avait
une de soirée du coup c'était juste le
body donc c'était passé sous-vêtements
pour actifier le tout VO d'ord merci
regardez saint-jeanpierre alors pour
tout vousire si je ne glisse pas au bout
du procéum à la fin de la soirée que je
ne me prends pas la robe je me rends pas
mon
talon bon vous avez compris les discours
c'est pas fait pour moi en tout cas
j'espère que le thème de cette élection
Miss France vous a plu pour ma part oui
c'est pourquoi on s'était dit
rendez-vous dans 10 ans
même jour même heure même scène merci
merci fier de participer à un concours
qui lit la beauté intérieure à la beauté
extérieure ce
soir je suis fière de me présenter à
vous à ce concours qui lit la beauté
intérieure à la beauté extérieure je
vais être honnête avec vous j'avais
écrit un discours il y a 2h j'ai envoyé
un message vocal à une amie et il y a
[Musique]
un fend fallir conclure ben oui c'est le
problème qu'on prépare
pas alors ce qui a beaucoup fait parler
aussi c'est le défilé en costume
régional tout représenter leur région
avec un costume fait surmesure c'était
pas mal on général ça passé puis est
arrivé Miss
Lorine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regard
[Applaudissements]
elle est venue fa s'est retrouvé en ncké
la meable mon frère non mais la p ça
doit être une quand il on dit tu vas
mettre ah ouais quand même elle elle
joue le jeu elle est dans son ba elle
elle était sympathique en plus elle elle
a quelque chose elle même après sur les
réseaux sociaux quand elle a vu tout
tout ce qui se passait par rapport à
Sonel elle en rigolait elle nous a dit
dans le bu elle nous a dit envoyez-moi
tous les tweets tout je veux rigoler ce
soir tu r on a aussi le droit à la bande
la bande de poolou dans le public à
chaque fois que la parole était à
Thierry Boman le mec
deieie chaque année mais arrêtez le
chocolatier il est hyper sympa ch je
sais mais il est pas du tout chocolatier
fait la pub pour chocolat vous êtes des
ouf mais c'est mais le gars il est pas
chocolatier c'est
form journalist n'importe
quoi du tout mais qu con il fait la pour
le chocolat
journaliste
toutand sans déconner pas du tout il est
il fait de la pub pour le chocolat et en
plus il donne c'est lui qui appelle au
vote ouais non il fait que ça il fait
que Miss France et le chocolat allez et
ben il avait des potes qui arrêtaient
pas de se retourner euh et de faire
coucou à la caméra à chaque fois qu'il
parlait poman cétait con bonsoir
Jean-Pierre bonsoir Cindy bonsoir à tous
ravi de vous retrouver une fois de plus
oui vous l'avez compris c'est à présent
à vous chez vous de faire entendre votre
voix et vous pouvez voter où que vous
vous trouviez en France métropolitaine
ou en outreem vous pouvez voter où que
vous soyez dans le Nord le Sud l'Est ou
l'ouest de l'Hexagone ce soir avec nous
alors votez dès à présent en envoyant le
numéro de votre Miss par SMS mais tout
est encore possible pour désigner les
cinq miss qui poursuivront l'aventure au
moment où je vous parle les scores sont
très proches pour nos cinq
finalistes et enfin c'est le moment de
la soirée la pauvre la chute de Miss
Guadeloupe on va laevir et regardez bien
Miss ti qui lui dégage la main en mode
m'entraîne pas dans ta chute ça c'était
extraordinaire
extraordinaire c'est bon lâche-moi là
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non franchement non franchement c'est
c'était pas mal alors tuis que tu étais
donc classement du public c'était Miss
gu
donc Miss Guadeloupe Miss nordpatcalé
Miss Provence Miss langdoc et classement
du jury Miss nordpatcalé donc en Miss
Provence Miss langdoc Miss guyan Miss
Guadeloupe et c'est vrai que donc tu été
voilà alors les votes des juris et du
public compent respectivement pour 50 %
lors de la finale attribué au candidat
donc voilà c'est pour ça que miss
norpatcalé est devenue Miss France
gillin in extrémis hein oua parce que ça
joue à une ou deux places dans le dans
le jury et moi justement audre je
voulais savoir à votre avis pourquoi
est-ce que le jury vous a placé si je
puis dire parmi les CIN si bas
euh je ne sais pas comment qu' non non
mais c'est quoi cette question c'est une
question de merde comment elle sait ils
vont dire va dire dire ils aim pas ma
gueule tu crois qu'ils vont le dire non
mais non mais tu toi vous allez voir sa
réponse mais sa réponse c'est que tu
l'as fais chier voilà ça réponse je
pense que les juris ont une vision du
coup de la Miss France peut-être qu'il
la voyait pas en moi et c'est c'est
comme ça franchement tu t'en fores parce
que all Conner non mais c'esti non mais
après c'est vrai qu'il y a une question
que tout le monde se pose mais que
personne va oser voilà c'est à partir du
moment où le juré est un jury uniquement
de femme est-ce que le vote aurait été
le même s'il avait été comme dans le
public des hommes et des femmes qui
votent voilà ou ah pas mal bonne
question bravo ça tu vois voilà tu vois
la différenceent toelle non bah moi je
la vois l'intelligence je vois non non
non pas du tout mais voilà non mais
c'est vrai que ça ça c'est une bonne
question parce que c'est vrai que tu as
été c'est vrai que c'est c'est des il y
avait que des femmes dans le jury
d'ailleurs je pense ça c'était une
petite erreur je suis désolé je suis
d'accord avec toi parce c'est 50% s le
public 50 % le jury on en parlera demain
d'ailleurs parce que moi j'adore EV et
je trouve que c'est une Miss France
formidable mais du coup malheureusement
les haters et les gens méchants et mal
attentionné tout ça et on voit qu'il y
en a beaucoup et ça jette un discrédit
sur cette nomination qui n'a aucune
raison voilà parce qu'on se dit en gros
ouais mais en gros elle a été sauvée par
des femmes un jury de femme donc des
femmes qui aiment pas forcément les
enfin c'est juste catastrophique voilà
et j'aurais c'est pour ça que depuis le
début je trouvais que c'était une
mauvaise idée alors l'année dernière il
y a une une intelligence artificielle
qui avait prédit kindira Enio d'ailleurs
qui c'est très belle
sublime je revu par on l'a pas vu
franchement elle a tellement évolué elle
a 18 ans je crois 18 là elle a 19 ans
plus forcément c'est vrai que c'est
mathématique on prend un an tous les an
tu voisis heureusement que tu es venu
elle serait victorieuse l'intelligence
artificielle avait dit l'année dernière
Indira en donc l'intelligence
artificielle avait trouvé la miss et
cette année elle avait prédit que ce
serait carlchir Bchir misc d'Azur qui
serait élu elle était mais était dans le
top 3 des favorites mais elle est
finalement arrivée 12e du top 15 et n'a
pas été sélectionnée pour la finale
peut-être la faute son discours
exactement parce qu'elle a un trou de
mémoire C pendant son un petit bug
pendant son discours la pauvre Carla
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'elle a
qu'elle a qu'elle a qu'elle qu'elle a
loupé et il y avait et Miss Provence
aussi qui avait qui était fortement
soutenue également voilà en tout cas
franchement Audrey bravo à toi qu'est-ce
que tu vas faire maintenant AUD ben je
vais retourner en guyen très proch ement
tu repars quand je sais dans la semaine
dans la semaine et donc j'ai hâte de
retrouver la population guanaise parce
qu' m'ont beaucoup seenu c'est vrai que
le monde des miss a y a il y a pas
forcément énormément d'engouement autour
de de ce titre de base mais c'est vrai
que cette année explosion en Guyenne je
pense que c'est parce qu'il y a eu le
voyage de préparation aussi qui s'est
déroulé en Guyenne du coup j'ai vraiment
hâte de pouvoir voir aussi tous les
rendez-vous que que j'ai parce que c'est
je pense que c'est le début d'une
nouvelle aventure et ben on te souhaite
vraiment le meilleur en tout cas alors f
Gill donc c'est la Miss France ses
cheveau courts sont un symbole de la
diversité féminine elle est revenue
dessus lors de sa première interview sur
TF1 au JT regardez vous êtes la première
Miss France à porter les cheveux courts
et vous avez d'ailleurs insisté sur ce
détail dans votre présentation hier
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir un peu tordu le coup à des
clichés sur ce que doit être une Miss
France aujourd'hui oui ça change un
petit peu de des Miss qu'on a connu
avant forcément après j'ai pas envie
d'être connu comme la miss aux cheveux
courts évidemment mais oui ça change on
dit toujours que pour être Miss il faut
entrer dans une case avoir fait l'école
de Miss pas du tout faut juste être
comme on est faut juste le vouloir et
avoir envie
oui il y a eu il y a eu il y a eu
beaucoup il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
haters sur les r qui ont vent un a Dieu
d'fferlement ex comme si on lui
reprochait ses chev cheveux courts de
pas
avoirè même dit que c'était la candidate
des W justement cheveux cour très maigre
pas de féminité vraiment enfin c'était
de toute façon le corps des femmes est
toujours soumis va Malama souvenez-vous
on disait qu'elle était trop ronde elle
elle est trop maigre enfin ça ne va
jamais donc en fait ces jeunes filles
elles s'assument et tant mieux et elles
disent au monde bah on fait on est comme
on est et on vous voilà les femmes sont
30 fois enfin 30 je crois 30 % plus
soumises aux haters que les hommes m
incroyable être une femme alors vous
êtes l'exception qui confirme la règle
mais elle a bien répliqué à ses
critiques hein elle a tout de suite
répliqué avec fermeté ouais parce que
les gens oublient quand même que ce sont
des jees des jeunes filles qui ont 18 20
ans elles sont encore toutes jeunes donc
laissezles laissez-les évoluer grandir
enfin foutez le la paix quoi merci en
tout cas d'avoir été avec nous Audrey
merci on te souhaite les meilleurs
euh il est 20h57